hello my name is reto Meier and I'm Ian
Neil Lewis we'll be looking at football
apps and taking a deep dive into low
latency high efficiency data transfers
all in 30 minutes in this week's app
clinic the most controversial aspect of
this week's app clinic is the name
football soccer either way we're talking
about the world game that is the
otherworld game that isn't baseball
American football or cricket which
actually I think is probably you know
more worldly well certainly more worldly
than any of the examples you can I just
want to I just want to make sure that we
understand that rato wrote the script
for this and when I hear football I'm
still thinking yeah when he when he he
is football he thinks throwing a ball
exactly we're talking about a
rectangular pitch to 45 minute halves
and no hands except the hand of God
really is that what they say when
they're doing soccer so I say what I'm
doing soccer
nice all right to help us out this week
we have a new bug droid mascot the
extremely exclusive uncanny reto meier
doppelganger I had to uh do things to
get this little guy things that I'm not
comfortable talking about but don't let
that take away from enjoying the
addition of our newest and most
productive team member he just sits
there
yeah it's he's not making us go
backwards and that my friend is forward
progress now all we need to do is find a
bug droid that's an uncanny resemblance
to me and we can put our early
retirement plans into action
excellent so this week we're talking
football or soccer the only thing more
fun than playing is watching and the
only thing more exciting than a game is
tracking all the games and that's what
this week's apps are all about why
didn't we do this with beer is that
thing do you have beer what I think
that's a sporting thing right sport idea
goes together like sport and beer huh
all I had today was a mountain Dew well
so here's a few of things that we looked
at with each app any sports tracking app
is going to live or diet based on the
depth and breadth of their coverage if
there's a team player or country that
you want to follow and isn't
you're gonna find another one that does
include it so that breath needs to be
matched by depth for every league I
let's say I'm a fan I want to be able to
track all the games in the ladder and
each player and their statistics all the
way down to live commentary maybe some
clips of fantastic plays if your sport
has them and any other information
that's going to make my join manure
intense and all that surface area means
that navigation can become really
important as does the use of things like
notifications and getting regular
updates so it's really easy to get lost
if you start pivoting around teams and
players and data and statistics so you
really need to be able to easily
navigate around and find your way back
out once you've dug in as far as it can
be exactly and that's especially
important with this work do it you know
I have to admit I think there are more
soccer teams in this world and then
grains of sand on all the oceans
throughout time but it applies to a lot
of other things too and it's even if
you're not into sport I think that the
things we'll be talking about today
apply to anything where there's a large
catalogue of data that can be viewed in
many different ways and where you're
likely to only be interested in a few
pieces per user
but each user has their own favorite
piece that they really want to get to
and would be pissed off if they couldn't
get to it quickly absolutely it's
similarly with teams participating in
lots of different layers playing several
games a week getting updates from all of
these apps when a game starts or when
your team scores is really important but
you've got to make sure that this
doesn't come at the price of decreased
battery life so today's fixture includes
three apps wait you wrote this and then
it says today's fixture what is a
fixture fixture a fixture is a schedule
in the context of support really okay
today learning it's German every day on
the app clinic right so today's first
down includes some we have thought mob
game plan and sporty will take a look at
each then
spend the last 10 15 minutes diving deep
into how these apps can ensure that you
get your updates quickly but without
draining your battery yeah so let's get
started with a look at fought mob now
fought mob recently released a brand new
update that includes a bunch of
beautiful new redesign elements and that
puts it a long way along the path of
becoming pure Android their experience
starts off really well it's got a great
Google Play landing page that includes a
fantastic banner and a perfect
silhouette logo that could still be a
little bit bigger I think if we were
gonna feature these guys we'd need that
logo to be 2 or 3 times bigger than it
is just so it would show up and I can
say this with with some authority
because I am about 10 feet away from a
monitor that is showing this logo at
about 6 inches across and I can't read
it that's sure and in fact you could you
could pretty happily take up the full
sort of side just behind Ian's head
there right you can actually see the
whole thing but it's you've got that
sort of a shape underneath the leg and
you could take up pretty much all of
that space with with the shield without
it you know becoming obstructive it's a
small quibble but it ends up being very
important for us for marketing traveling
and marketing is kind of a big play so a
lot of the things we're going to talk
about with fought mob are along the
lines of these more nitpicky things it
is a really nice app looks very
professional and they've gotten off on
the right foot straight away here in a
landing page this looks like something
that people have spent real money
building and that gives you that
impression that it's going to be
something worth Mommy downloading so
let's see who's gonna be talking it's
gonna be me right so once you get into
the app that feeling really continues
the overall layout is clean it's
uncluttered and it does a good job of
following the design guidelines it
definitely has the depth and breadth
that we talked about and does a really
good job of laying that all out in a
fairly intuitive manner the views the
view pager throughout the app really
well to make the whole thing feel
engaging dynamic and fluid and they've
integrated well with the platform this
features like add to calendar for each
of the fixtures so that you can
basically use your existing notification
techniques rather than having this app
re implement all the things which are
already built into the calendar app so I
really like that
biggest area for improvements there
relatively subtle and they're relatively
nitpicky so bear with me but I think
that if you know if you consider some of
these things then we're really going to
be able to consider this as a really
example of the way that these sorts of
apps can be made now first off they've
introduced a couple of custom controls
which aren't immediately obvious how
they should be used the first is this
toggle at the top of each activity we
could gin just about C which says all
it's kind of in the middle up there but
without clicking it there's no way to
determine what it actually does so if
you click it then it becomes clear that
you have a choice between all matches or
just the live matches and they used a
similar toggle throughout the app to do
things like having the alerts turned off
or on but until you click it you don't
actually know what it controls now you
generally want to avoid this ante
pattern within your apps geeks like us
we're gonna gonna press everything on
the screen just to see what it does in
the hope that it does something cool but
most users treat their devices and
computers a little differently in fact
it's more common to find people who are
worried that there's some magic button
or key press combination is going to
delete all of their data and post new
photos of them on the internet you don't
want to confront folks like this with a
mystery button anywhere in your UI you
know there's a there's another issue
with that particular button type and
that is that when you yeah there we go
when you have a button like this that
that's a toggle button and it has a
label on it there's a legitimate
question as to whether the label
represents the state that the button is
currently in or the state that you will
enter when you press that button yeah so
I think the the right thing to do is
have a toggle where you have both
choices and you can go back and forth
between them exactly you want to
basically have it obvious what it does
and obvious what the current state is so
similarly there's a a ladder button at
the top right of each header which seems
like it should be well
doesn't like seem like it should be
doing anything and because it's really
it's too small and so it's the same sort
of thing that you'll see here with above
each game there's a little header that
tells you what league it's in and
there's a little button next to it which
will allow you to view the standings in
that leagues ladder
the thing is is that those touch targets
are less than 40 dips square which means
they're really too small to hit with
your finger which if you're used to
these sorts of apps you're not expecting
to be touch targets because they're too
small to be real touch targets so you
really want to make sure that all these
things are big enough to be able to be
touched
easily and to make it obvious when these
things are touchable now overall I found
the navigation pattern throughout the
app a little bit confusing in particular
the use of the upper-40s
it often worked a lot more like a
substitute back button then it did an up
direction within a semantic hierarchy of
the app so it's a lot of words but what
I'm saying is for example if I navigate
from you know from this screen here
within to it within a match and then
from within the match go to look at a
specific team and then I press up what
I'm expecting to see then is something
like a list of teams what actually
happens is it takes me back to the
previous match now that doesn't really
make semantic sense in that hierarchy
like team doesn't correspond to a single
match it corresponds to a bunch of maps
or to a league so you really want to sit
down and spend a little bit of time just
basically mapping out all of your
activities and how they all correspond
to each other in that more hierarchical
fashion you know a lot of people get
back and up mixed mixed up and I think
that the fact that the UP button
actually points to the left doesn't help
things but it can be a little confusing
but it's it's impossible to to overstate
the significance of it when you get into
this type of app where there's a large
catalogue of data because with the sort
of large catalog you want to be able to
pivot your data in multiple directions
you want to be able to jump around kind
of like you do you know on the world
wide web or something and just like on
world wide web on a web page you have a
single let's say golden hierarchy that's
how that's the way the the webpage was
sort of meant to be browsed but then you
have cross links everywhere so that you
can get to what you're looking for
quickly the back button will take you
back through your cross links very
nicely and that's essential Android
behavior but if you if you want to get
up the hierarchy in some way that's what
the app affordance is for absolutely
final nitpick is if you have a look here
you can see that there draw
implementation is slightly off based on
the design guidelines say you should be
doing what it should be doing is just
sliding the content beneath the action
bar in and out the action bar itself
should always be consistent and
stationary along the entire top so the
only other thing I wanted to mention
navigating around the app the first time
resulted in a lot of loading screens as
I was swiping left and right those sorts
of things totally understandable
it might be worth trying to be a little
more aggressive in your prefetching I'm
going to go into a bit more detail on
how you can do that without being a
battery drain a little bit later in
today's show our next step is gameplan
and they've got the the right idea for
their logo and banner but both can do
with a little bit of extra polish yeah I
think the the the sense that I get here
is that they spent a great deal of money
on an absolutely gorgeous picture and
then gave it to an intern with
PowerPoint to put their their logo on I
think that having something a little bit
more distinctive for their logo would
really help yeah exactly that's
generally the biggest challenge you're
gonna have when you take a nap that you
steer to start off building for yourself
because it does something that you want
and I think that's a fantastic reason to
start building apps because you want the
app and it's kind of what got me
interested in smartphone to development
to begin with it's like wow I can just
build an app to do anything the big
challenge when you want to take that
beyond yourself and your friends and
turning something which has a real broad
appeal and get will get you a lot of
downloads is that extra level of
professionals and that extra level of
polish and overall that's probably the
biggest advice that we've got for game
plan overall so as you can see the
initial view is really intimidating it
gives the impression of being either
designed for an expert or for one
individual as well as lacking a certain
amount of overall polish it's not
necessarily a problem but it will
discourage new or casual users from
getting involved and in this is an area
with the it's probably the area with the
most low-hanging fruit that you can
harvest in the form of getting new users
and so the further that feeling is also
using some non-standard UX mechanisms so
if you go to add a team you do that by
searching and it will sort of start
searching through the database and have
a little modal dialog that says hit back
if you want to stop searching we
makes sense but is weird and confusing
and just doesn't feel right well anytime
you have to put text on your screen that
says hit this button to do something
you've done it wrong yeah exactly you
want everything to be as intuitive as
possible to just feel normal feel like
it's the right way and to further that
feeling is there's also things like well
no I mean that's really it the risk here
is that you're going to be making giving
people unfamiliar things and they're
going to find that intimidating once you
get some data into the app you can see
that that depth and breadth of coverage
is there which is a great stuff so I
really think that the next step for the
developers here is to sit down and
really think about a design that's
really going to draw users in something
clean something intuitive easy to use
and I think that's probably the next
step here before we go into too much
detail there so the last step we're
going to look at today is spory it is
I love the banner I hate the icon it's a
rounded rectangle with a gradient feel
like I'm looking at your banner and I'm
seeing like real branding there it's
like strong colors strong images you
know something very distinctive and then
I look at the logo that's like it's it's
so sort of generic and boring it's got
the right guy whatever is yeah why
haven't they used their their football
player silhouette in the iconic fit well
it would look nice it would get you out
of that whole rounded rectangle with a
little shiny part yeah exactly so I
think that that would be in a really
easy way I think to straightaway make
this landing page even more distinctive
and more than that once the app is
installed the users have a lot of apps
installed right you need to make your
icon from in which people are going to
remember and you can see that they've
stuck a little football in here which is
almost a hint that like well we used to
have just the the logo and no one knew
what the hell it was so we added the
football and so people have it but now
it looks like you're part of the
football Network or something yeah
exactly
looks like a badge exactly right so
you're heading in the right direction
but keep going there I think is the the
big tip I mean this is nitpicky stuff
but from a lot of what we've been
hearing from developers is they want to
get more downloads they want to have
more successful merchants
and it's these little nitpicky things
which us as developers were like come on
it's just an icon who cares well in
speaking of merchandise and remember the
way that people bought your app was by
looking at this banner that's far and
away the most important first impression
they're going to get and then once they
download it there's nothing about that
banner that translates into the icon
except for some subtleties of the color
scheme and it's not a very unusual color
scheme so I don't think I'd be able to
find it later on secondly you want to
make sure people can find it up they've
installed because a lot of people will
do what we do on the app clinic which is
download 3 or 4 apps which you all
supposedly do about the same thing and
then just go through each of them know
if they can't even find it then they
don't have that association with the
great experience that they started here
exactly so let's move on so the app
itself is great
there's functionality there's a lot it
has a lot of similarities with fun mob
they've got a great clean and dynamic
design that's clearly inspired by holo
it does a great job of following our
guidelines so we're super happy about
that and we think they did a good job of
layout but in terms of feedback it's not
always obvious exactly what is gonna be
clickable on this screen and in fact
initially what we did was just sort of
click nothing and we just assumed that
that we were looking at a fairly shallow
app that didn't have a lot of depth you
found that they've fall into the same
tiny touch targets trap that foot mob
had so I don't know if they tested this
on larger devices or they just have
unnaturally small hands over in soccer
watching country that's about it well
that's why we don't use that hands when
we play soccer yeah now I understand oh
that's the answers the whole question
for me so yeah we need to make sure that
the touch targets are a little larger
and there's also a lot of features that
almost feels like the problem here is
that the app didn't want to add too many
activities or too many screens so they
tried to cram everything into one screen
and then it became a little bit
impenetrable as to what was active and
what would do what there's also a lot of
features that are flood hidden away in
the overflow menu so it might be nice to
move some of the more common features to
the action bar
and maybe even hide some less commonly
used features onto a different page
entirely to think about how people are
going to use your app in the most
general use case and try and program for
that but the biggest issue with the app
is around navigation and once you start
digging in it's so easy to lose your
place it's just like we were talking
about before when you have a gigantic
catalogue of data you need to be able to
jump around you need to be able to pivot
but you also need to find your way back
to where you came otherwise you're lost
like oh let's say Hansel and Gretel in
the forest where they were left by their
unkind stepmother
that's why most apps these days have or
most websites these days have something
called breadcrumbs and the up affordance
is our version of that we don't
obviously have enough space to put an
entire breadcrumb bar but you should
think about the up affordance that way
it's gonna lead you back to the home
page as quickly as possible now I do
want to highlight the great job they've
done with updates and notifications that
you can use these little plus icons that
you see on the screen to track any game
or team or player and spory is going to
give you the notifications whenever
whoever you're tracking starts playing
or scores or anything important happens
that's an awesome feature and they
implemented it right it doesn't drain
your battery which is by far the most
important thing we can say about all of
these apps is that you know they need to
be implemented efficiently because
they're transferring tremendous amounts
of data that has real time implications
and if you can put the the tablet up on
screen Daniel will we'll have a look at
it panels here so you can see that
they've got the fixed users all on the
Left without having too much white space
and they've still got a nice view pager
implementation so you can scroll around
and see what games are coming up and
then clicking on either on any of these
fixtures is going to update the
right-hand panel we have all of your
game information and again they've got a
view pager no it's not a view pager
interesting so what you can see here is
they've actually designed a great tablet
version of the app they've used the
the split panels here so you can see
that they've got the fixtures all on the
left without having too much white space
and they still got a nice view pager
implementation so you can scroll around
and see what games are coming up and
then clicking on either of on any of
these fixtures is going to update the
right-hand panel we have all of your
game information and again they've got a
view pager no it's not a view pager
interesting should be a view pager so
that should work the same way it doesn't
at the moment need to click each of the
headings you know that's really
unfortunate because one of the things
that I think is absolutely crucial with
an app like this is to have animations
everywhere because you need to
understand which data you're leaving and
which data is coming in if it just kind
of blinks on and off it can be very
easily to mentally lose your place and
so I wanted to highlight this because
there's actually the only one of the
three apps we're looking at today which
has a tablet implementation and this is
a really good example of a kind of app
which would do well to have such an
implementation because a lot of people
are going to be sitting on their couch
with their tablets in their hands maybe
watching sport on TV and browsing
through fixtures games matches players
standings and those sorts of things on
their tablet so as a content consumption
device tablets are awesome and this is
exactly the sort of app that you want to
be able to have a more optimized design
version for your tablet owners so how
did they do it how did these developers
create apps which have all of this data
which gets updated really frequently
keep it all fresh keep it all low
latency without draining all the
batteries so I'm going to spend the last
few minutes of today's app clinic doing
a bit of a deep dive into low latency
updates which still effectively use the
battery so where do you start off so a
good app is like a good Butler right so
you are going to want to have all of
that data on screen as quickly as you
can I love the fact that you have this
later you've been using this slide for
years and and yet it resonates with me
not at all because I've never had a
butler good or otherwise uh closest I've
ever come is down Yardley marathon nice
well that's yeah that's my experience
with a butler as well but you know
um see if you can can squeeze that into
a slightly smaller look on screen there
you go
okay so what we're saying here is really
is that you want to have your
information you want to have it when you
want it you don't want to wait for it at
all and so what that translates into is
that you need to figure out what that
trade-off is between latency and battery
life so basically you know the less
latency you have the shorter battery
life you have and the reality is that
that trade-off for most users it wants
to be here right you want to have
maximum battery life zero latency which
is kind of a hard trick to pull off but
what that translates into for us as
developers is you need to make a
compromise you need to make a decision
about how are you going to do those
downloads when are you going to do those
downloads now it's obvious to say that
you should do transfer as little info as
you can as infrequently as you can but
for apps like this that doesn't really
work you need the data it needs to come
in there's lots of it that's a big
strength of the app so you need to
figure out how can you do it efficiently
now it turns out that the way that the
mobile radio state works actually
impacts how you need to make that
decision so the way it actually works is
it'll be on standby mode drawing as
little battery current as possible then
as soon as someone or some app wants to
download data it's going to power up
that radio that takes a couple of
seconds of latency then the radio is
going to be on full power transmitting
and receiving doing everything it needs
to and then when the last packet is sent
it's going to stop it's going to say
well we don't want to you know if
someone's browsing the web and they've
just landed on a page we don't want to
have to cost him another two seconds
every time they click a link so we're
gonna wait somewhere around 5 to 10
seconds before we go into like a low
battery mode and then we're going to
weigh probably another 30 seconds or so
before we go back into like the the
proper standby mode so what does that
tell us well it means that if you've got
fragmented network traffic like this
where you're doing little updates every
30 seconds and big data transfers
whenever you need to you're actually
going to result in a really inefficient
battery profile where suddenly you've
got the device is staying on active for
a huge amount of time just because every
30 seconds it's powering it back up it's
it's basically never
go back into full stand but I know one
of one of the saddest things about this
particular behavior is that something
that you know if you were on a desktop
would make a huge amount of sense is is
horrible for a mobile environment and
that's going and checking to see if
there's anything you need to download
exactly it's just as expensive in many
cases to do an entire download as it is
to just check and see if something is
available precisely and so all of the
things which we're going to be talking
about now are ways in which you can make
sure that all your data transfers happen
basically in one go so you're already
paying the price of bringing up the
batter the the radio getting the battery
drain associated with that just do all
of your transfers as much as you can and
so what that comes down to is doing
things like prefetching so if you're
going to be downloading some data
download a bunch of data it's going to
be more efficient batch and bundle and
preempt so anytime you've got data which
isn't or a transfer which isn't
particularly time-sensitive just batch
it just hold on and then the next time
you have something which is
time-sensitive send it all in one go
this is particularly useful for things
like ads for analytics anything like
that which isn't time-sensitive you know
this is actually the hardest thing to
for a beginner to implement but once you
get into the habit of doing it this way
it becomes a beautiful way to implement
your app that all of the all the data
that you're planning to transfer is kept
in some sort of form on the disk of the
device ion on permanent storage so that
everything is always persisted and that
gives you not only better Network
behavior but also better behavior in
terms of being partially connected or
having interruptions in your app or
catastrophic failure recovery absolutely
so I like to think of this as the big
cookie model so very small number of
very big transfers and some of the ways
that you can implement this pattern this
the first and the most simple the most
powerful is what M was alluding to which
is using Google Cloud messaging so
rather than having some sort of polling
of like oh we're going to check every
five minutes to see if there's something
new forget that do it all server-side
have one server multiple service
checking all the different sources of
data and when
you've got something which a user has
said hey I'm interested in all the form
games they've marked that they've told
you that as soon as you see something
relevant you ping them you tell them
specifically hey you should you should
do an update now because there's been a
change this is much more efficient than
doing polling yourself you also want to
do in this we've sort of said this
already transfer as much as possible
minimize the number of sessions delay
time insensitive transfers batching
basically everything that you're doing
and prefetching which is part of this so
try and download only what you'll need
but try and download everything you
think you'll need so that's really a
balance where you're saying figure
people are going to use your app for the
next two to five minutes and make sure
that there's enough data there so that
you're not going to have to do another
poll another connection to your service
within that time frame which means that
if you're looking at one page on a
viewpager
you want to make sure you've got
basically everything else horizontally
along that strip and probably two swipes
worth a vertical data as well the cost
for downloading that text data is going
to be significantly smaller than the
cost of having to spin up the radio in
order to download that data later at the
very least I mean when you're talking
about spinning up the radio for a
certain number of seconds versus the
amount of text that you're going to
transfer over let's say a gzip
compressed HTTP connection you can
actually get a lot of data within a
fairly small number of packets you got
to keep in mind that by spinning up the
radio you're gonna keep it on for
somewhere between 10 10 seconds in a
minute so anything you can download in
that amount of time is actually going to
be more efficient than having to
potentially download data that you don't
need yeah you obviously don't want it to
download redundant data but only because
it's likely that the user will be
charged for it yes but you do want to
download all of the new data you can
usually if you have some sort of
operational transform or time stamping
or just anything that allows you to
figure out what's new and what isn't and
apply that to your local persistent
storage that's the best way to deal with
an app like this absolutely and while
we're talking prefetching it's worth
noting that not all networks transfer
data equally so you can see here in this
snippet of code and all of these slides
are going to be available so much more
easily readable than off the video what
we're doing here is simply saying well
let's have a look at how fast this
network is and download more data if we
have a
faster connection this is especially
true not just because of the speed
implications but also because the faster
networks tend to have a bigger battery
drain so it's even more important that
you minimize the number of times that
you're basically spinning up the radio
to do another data transfer if you can't
use cloud-to-device messaging if you
just need to do regular polling for
whatever reason try and figure out a way
that you don't need to use regular
polling but if if you've done that and
there really is no alternative make sure
that you use inexact repeating alarms
and this is a way of being able to set a
regular polling alarm which is going to
allow you to synchronize all of those
things at the same time so that
basically it so it's a way of letting
the system do some batching for you it's
also worth trying to make sure that
you're not using wake alarms if at all
possible for this sort of thing so that
you're not draining the battery while
the user isn't even using their phone
similarly if you are doing that sort of
Paul it's worth considering this sort of
inactivity back off where a user isn't
using your app they haven't opened it in
three days it's probably not as
important to have that low latency data
so do keep track of how often the app is
being used and consider modifying your
refresh frequency based on their
frequency of your app use all the
details for this are available in this
training class transferring data without
draining the battery so all of that in
all the information I've shared quickly
here is available in much more detail at
that class so our next step is to take a
closer look at today's apps and see how
close they are to being pure Android so
to do that we're going to pass them
through each of these checklists so if
you're the developer or mob spory
or game plan do you get in touch and me
and Ian will try to provide you a little
bit more detailed feedback on what your
next steps should be if you want to you
know make it to that next level right
now we don't have a whole lot of time
but I do just want to point out for
those of you watching my home that
writer who wrote the script for for this
show did in fact capitalize the M in me
thereby making this read sort of like
the King James Bible just wanted to
mention that let's move on so until then
you can find our existing pure Android
this collection at bitly slash pure
Android and you can nominate your app
for consideration by adding it to our
Trello page at bitly slash app clinic
Trello the we'll be back next week
hopefully neither one of us has the
plague again yea as crust don't forget
to join Roman Nick and Adam on Android
design in action next Tuesday until next
week I'm reto Meier and i'm ian ni-lewis
and this has been the App clinic